hello welcome to ed talks with khan
academy where we talk to
experts in the field of education
today we have with us sophie bosmany who
is with khan kidz and she's going to
update us on
what's going on with pond kids our app
for two to eight-year-olds so we are
looking forward to hearing what she has
to say
before we get started for a reminder
that khan academy is a non-profit and we
rely on donations to keep up the work
that we are doing
so you will find at khanacademy.org
donate the place where you can make a
donation
whatever you can give is appreciated and
thank you for helping us to continue to
do this work
we also want to recognize a a few
companies that really in the time of
covet 19 stepped up to help us make sure
we could meet the increasing demand for
what we do that includes bank of america
a t google.org novartis fastly and
general motors thank you
and finally if you have missed some of
these egg talks or home rooms you can
find us in your podcast app at homeroom
with sal and replay the audio versions
of these discussions so we look forward
to seeing you there as well and with
that
i will welcome sophie thank you for
joining us today
thank you for having me kristen it's
great to see you and i'm really excited
to be talking about khan academy kids
excellent so
let's start off tell us a little bit
about yourself what's your role at khan
academy kids
well it actually goes back
a little way when i worked at khan
academy so i started out
working on khan academy thinking a lot
about how we get into school districts
around the country so i worked as a
partnerships manager at khan academy for
a few years
and then just after khan academy
acquired duckduck moose which was a
for-profit suite of early learning apps
that wanted to have even more impact and
so joined khan academy i
found the pool of early childhood
education and and those littlest
learners
so exciting that i came and worked on
khan academy kids and now i work on khan
academy kids i work
on
strategy and i work on our partnerships
with
preschools and with school districts
around the country
that's great so we often have students
who are watching and many of us are in
careers that maybe aren't the things
that students who are in
middle or high school think about how
did you end up in this this role of
partnerships and linking people together
oh that's a good question and i think
it's something that i like to talk about
a little bit because it was kind of a
roundabout path and it's not like when i
was in high school i i thought you know
i want to go and work for
what i think is the best ed tech company
in the world and and do partnerships
that certainly wasn't on my radar uh you
know i i grew up in australia i don't
know if you can tell from my accent
a little bit
and you know i i had um
really supportive parents who so wanted
me to pursue
whatever i i was interested in and they
had a really strong preference for that
to be
um
medicine or the law that i would i would
maybe become a doctor or an attorney and
so i did go down that path and became an
attorney in australia
and i loved that work and at some point
that work brought me
out to the us and that was to study and
to work and so i was an international
student out here and doing a graduate
degree and that's when i discovered khan
academy
and you know i thought a lot about
well what is it that i i really love
doing and that's connecting people like
you said um it's thinking about okay
what are the big problems that we should
be solving and trying to prioritize
things because we can't quite do
everything and so a job in partnerships
and in strategy
came to make a lot of sense
but i i i don't want anyone to think
that that was a neat path or that that
made a lot of sense at the time there
were certainly times where i thought oh
gosh i i spent all this time going to
law school maybe i should uh you know
use that or
um
and it's turned out that that i do i i
do use my law degree and i i use a lot
of other skills as well so
yeah my my message would be
you know enjoy that journey and get
excited about the fact that you might
not even
know
sitting here right now
what it is that you might end up really
loving doing uh in five or ten years
time which was definitely my experience
that was totally my experience as well
and and i can tell a story now from
where i am of how i got here that sounds
like it was all a plan
but it was not and at any particular
time there were different forks that
would have led me in different
directions so i totally agreed and i
always like to tell people to just be
open to what might come down the path
and as opportunities arise as well
um that's that's trust me i had no idea
you'd been to law school even though we
have worked together for a while so i'm
glad i asked
yeah let's let's switch over to khan
academy kids for those who aren't
familiar with it
tell us a little bit about it how is it
different than the khan academy
main site that folks go to
fill us in
yes so khan academy kids is a part of
khan academy so we all work under one
umbrella on the same mission of
providing a free world-class education
to anyone anywhere and
khan academy kids takes that mission and
says okay in order to deliver on that
it's going to be really important that
kids arrive at third grade able to read
and able to be in the classroom and
feeling um like they're enjoying math
and the way that we approach that at
khan academy kids is we've built
a program that covers all of those
things so it's not just one subject
and it's in a mobile app which is really
important for younger learners to be
able to drag and drop things and have
something uh that it
meets their needs before they can read
and actually navigate a desktop computer
and so i think you're seeing some of the
footage of just how fun and bright and
cool it is
um but the the big differences i would
say
uh
khan academy is for
grades 2 through 12 and it has math and
ela for grades 2 through 12 and a range
of other subjects for middle and high
school
khan academy kids is for ages two years
to eight years so it goes up to and
through second grade getting kids ready
for third grade when they would move on
and use khan academy so that's one big
difference
i mentioned that khan academy kids is a
mobile app so the way that you access
khan academy kids is through the app
store that you use so that could be the
apple app store it could be google play
it could even be amazon
and then it would be on your mobile
device so here we can see there's a
tablet being used but it could also be a
mobile phone or even a chromebook
khan academy is also available
on the app store as an app it's a
different separate app so you would
search for khan academy versus khan
academy kids in the app store they're
two different apps in the app stores and
khan academy is also available on the
web so on your desktop computer that's
one one big difference
uh i would say
though there are more similarities than
there are differences you know the idea
is to make learning really joyful
to meet learners where they are at
whether they're struggling with
something or really
accelerating and
loving a particular area of their
learning
um and then also
increasingly the goal is to support
teachers and their students in
classrooms and both khan academy and
khan academy kids
are doing that so i think that's some of
the main similarities and differences
between khan academy and khan academy
kids
i love that yeah i
i usually think of it as thinking we're
headed towards the the same goal but
kids who are two to eight years old
developmentally are very different than
older kids and just
designing one experience really isn't
possible and so having these two
separate experiences really gives us the
strength of being able to
really as you said meet students where
they are so
love it that sounds great
so i've been poking around in the new
content and i saw some new yoga videos
that i was really excited to see there's
a fun one where they do animal poses so
yoga poses that are named after animals
and all of that
so
with that and other things what if you
guys you folks released over the past
few months
well yeah i'm glad you noticed the yoga
i'm so excited about that so at khan
academy kids and it's the same at khan
academy this time of year is really busy
for us because we are releasing a lot of
new content and features in time for the
new school year so that teachers and
students can get excited about them as
they as they get learning after the
summer and so we worked really hard this
past really the past year to build a lot
of new content you mentioned the yoga
that was part of khan academy kids is is
really about thinking
about
the whole child not just their abcs in
one two threes and so we've always loved
getting kids up and moving
and
fostering this idea that being ready for
kindergarten and ready to thrive at
school is about more than just academics
kids need to know how to be in the
classroom they need to be confident and
healthy and so we partnered with aloe
yoga
and they have a part of their program
called aloe gives and aloe gives
is now fully featured in the khan
academy kids app
it's a set of videos uh they're a few
minutes anywhere up to about five
minutes long with real uh people real
kids real yoga instructors in them which
i'm excited about
uh and cody bear doing yoga
it's not pretty rare doing yoga
as much as we would love to see that and
and cody certainly loves yoga and loves
to keep fit and healthy uh
we we thought our friends at aloe gibbs
could really help show us and you know
it's been amazing kristen we have had
lots of family sending in the most
adorable videos of uh them all you know
the whole family sometimes getting
involved in in doing their movement and
mindfulness each day
and uh for teachers we think it this
could translate well too because we're
seeing lots of teachers projecting the
app on their screen if they're lucky
enough to have one in their class or if
they're teaching remotely uh to share
their screen over zoom or whatever
platform they're using and then uh we
can we can all do yoga together so it's
something that we're seeing used at home
we're seeing it used a little bit in
classrooms and we're just super excited
about it i know yoga is a you know a
really important part of
my life and and um my mindfulness and so
yeah can't wait for kids to discover
that
that's fantastic so you talked about uh
some of the new titles that are
available too
uh can you give us a little bit more
detail on some of the books that are
available now
yeah so a big part of the
latest release that we're really excited
about for back to school is
covering second grade so we had a bunch
of kids who were just flying through our
app they were quickly running out of
activities and so
you know we couldn't keep up with them
they were they were going to get through
all of the first grade content for sure
so
we have built out second grade content
so we added
over 200
second grade lessons we added over a
hundred new animated videos that are in
the app and all that animation is done
you know sort of right behind me you can
see the little uh corner where we put
together the animations of our
characters so you can see sandy the
dingo and peck is the bird and olo the
elephant and ray of the red panda and
cody the bear cody narrates and takes us
through the app
so we added all those animations that
cover a range of activities we added
more coloring pages
in our create section which is really
really fun
uh we talked about the yoga that we
added
and we've added new books so khan
academy kids
is a combination of our original books
that are all created here in-house and
then also some partner books as well and
we partner with national geographic so
young explorer and bellwether media on
our non-fiction books
and we added a ton of new non-fiction
books some of them get really
deep in the science of things and uh
just super interesting and so
if you go
into the app and then go into the
library
you will see um most of the new content
if you're in second grade and you'll see
these banners that say new and you'll
see the yoga videos and you'll see the
new bellwether books and you'll see a
bunch of new original readers as well so
we're just really excited we think we
might have a chance this year kristin of
keeping up with all those learners who
are just racing through our content
it's a good challenge to have to try to
reach them and keep up with that
that is great
excellent so you talked about classrooms
and teachers and i know that that's been
a push too what are teachers told you
that they want and
and how have you met some of those
requests
yeah well firstly i just got to say
and it doesn't get said enough i don't
think that that teachers are absolutely
incredible and amazing we we had
teachers during school closures last
year reaching out to us and they were so
quick to adapt to online learning and
they were sharing their screen with the
khan academy kids app and then we built
an assignments feature so that they
could assign
targeted lessons for students who are
working at home
and then they have progress reports
where they can see
what is going on and we got a lot of
feedback when we launched those features
the assignments and the reports really
designed for remote learning at the time
um that the teachers were enjoying it
they were loving it and you know they
they wanted even more data and they
wanted even um better ways of assigning
the right thing to a student at the
right time which we were really happy to
hear
so
we just launched a new set of teacher
reports and so this is accessible if you
do
log in to the app as a teacher you'll
see that there is a
assignment section and a report section
and now teachers can assign directly
from these reports that's one of the
biggest changes we made so you can
imagine if you're a teacher and you see
that it's students struggling on
something and you want to reassign it
you don't want to go back out into the
library find that thing and assign it
that would be really clunky
and so now you can assign directly from
this report and it's really quick and
easy
the other thing that teachers were
asking for was i want to see a student's
score history on each lesson i don't
just want to see their their latest
attempt or their best attempt i want to
really know you know did they
exhibit a growth mindset did they really
work hard at mastering this um how how
can i see their journey to getting to
that check mark if it's you know a green
check mark
um and another big thing and this is
especially important when there has been
suspected learning loss is that
teachers and parents for that matter can
see
how far a student has progressed in a
particular learning domain
so they can start to see okay that might
have been a little bit disrupted we
spent some time out of school we spent
more time outdoors we learned more
things around the house all those were
good things and now we it's great to
have a sense of where we're at on a
particular learning domain and a
learning domain might be
a component of ela um it might be a
component of math so like um counting
uh might be part of a learning domain
and we'll get a good sense of where a
student is at so you know
all i can say is hats off to our
teachers we're training them already
it every year it feels like they're even
smarter about our our product connie how
many kids than we are they're teaching
us a ton about what works and what
doesn't when you actually take it into a
classroom or a virtual learning setup
uh and yeah it's just a it's a joy we we
um have some khan academy kids
ambassadors
as well and they are
just really amazing uh group of teachers
who
are spreading the word and and to that
end if anyone listening you know whether
you're a student or a teacher or a
district administrator or a parent or
yeah or none of the above
if you know of
districts that that would like to work
with us preschools particularly head
start preschools we're so interested in
reaching them
if you know
teachers
uh if you know parents i mean spreading
the word anyone who is involved in the
education of two to eight-year-olds
should know about khan academy kids i
think
excellent so i know in the the
uh report that got
flashed up there on the screen for a
minute the folks uh managed to catch
that one of the things that we talk
about a lot is mastery learning and then
it's not just about getting a score on a
particular assignment but thinking about
mastering a skill and so when you're
talking about domains like accounting
instead of saying you know thinking
about oh what was my score on this
assignment it's thinking about how well
do i understand
counting and it looks like your reports
are
designed to help kind of
teachers do both of those things
understand how a student did on a
particular assignment but also that
broader
domain and understanding how they're
making progress on that
that is that a fair statement
yeah that is a fair statement and you
know it it wasn't always that easy to
aggregate up to the skill or domain
level and that was something that our
teachers uh
asked for and so
that is really part of this new release
that we launched just a couple of weeks
ago and that teachers are starting to
use yeah that's exactly right great
great
so
you talked a little bit about last year
and the challenges teachers faced and
where they were
unfortunately it looks like we're not
out of the woods yet on some of these
challenges in getting kids to school and
where things are and i'm starting to see
some headlines about
what it attendance is looking like
coming into school particularly for
young learners what are what are you
seeing related to that
yeah i think we
had heard
throughout the summer all about the
excitement about heading back into the
classroom and we are still really
hopeful all the amazing work that's
going on at the state and district level
to make that safe for students i think
is is just a
incredible
uh there is
some hesitation
when it comes to
getting kids back into classrooms
and we are seeing and i think that's
what you were referencing kristin is
that the the uh
absence is really concentrated in those
younger years so
i think what some of the numbers coming
out of places like stanford university
in the last couple of weeks show when it
comes to enrollments in public schools
is that there
is
there are lower enrollment levels across
the board
and there are even lower enrollment
levels for lower grades
and
kindergarten is looking like the hardest
hit
and that is really you know a key age
group for
khan academy kids
and so some of the numbers we have is
that you know there are a million
children who were expected to be
enrolled
who are not enrolled
and not turning up to school
so far you know time will tell
and you know
close to a third of them
are kindergarten students
and so i think what i can say to folks
about that is that khan academy kids you
know whether
there's learning happening at home
or learning happening in the classroom
khan academy kids is a tool that can
support both arrangements
so we have parents who are working on a
lot of learning with kids at home
and they are able to chart the progress
of their child at home
and then share it with their teacher
whether they're learning remotely
through something like zoom virtual
school
or whether they do in fact make it back
into the classroom and so that is one
way we're supporting
parents and teachers at this time
particularly with younger kids
particularly if they're if they're not
ready to be back in the classroom yet
and i think
we will be able to show up on the screen
here some resources
we have here
and we'll put a link in the chat and
we've got a link up there now
khan dot co forward slash khan kids
dash parent resources
and this is where parents can go to get
a list of resources
and really these are around things like
structuring time so how might a parent
plan the week or the day
there are there's a link there you can
see now
called printables and that will link to
a bunch of
uh activities that really go beyond
being ordinary worksheets they um they
will link to the app they will have
activities that are out of the app and
get kids moving they will have cutouts
they will have craft they will have
creativity so you can see some of these
printables um are really helping parents
at home because we want to balance that
screen time on our app learning with our
characters and
working through printables
so
they're just some of the ways that we're
supporting learning at home
and so let me pause um ashley clark on
youtube hopefully that answers your
question of whether uh whether khan
academy kids can be used to for parents
who are homeschooling their kids
so are you going to interrupt you but
that question had just come in and
thought it was uh
right in line with what you you're
talking about
yeah great no i i think ashley i think
um
you saw that url there
reach out to us at khan academy kids
support if you have any trouble finding
anything but i think the beauty of it is
it's not all
in-app there's a lot going on outside of
our app as well for those little
learners
and yeah we've got we've got a lot of
parents who are relying on these
resources for a good part of their
learning program with their kids at home
excellent
and so
let's take a look at kids who
are going back into classrooms and what
we can do to support them
yeah well i think one of the big things
and it it sometimes feels a little bit
counterintuitive because there's a lot
of stress about learning loss going on
one you know one of the big things that
we're hearing is
let's take this slow when it comes to
picking up new resources and getting
right back into learning let's make sure
kids are feeling
uh you know confident in the classroom
everyone's been through a lot this this
past more than a year now
and so uh we are really
really excited for kids to get back and
and to you know meet their friends
sometimes for the first time to meet
their their new teacher and then as
learning begins we're working with
teachers to weave khan academy kids into
the school day
and into um homework or in work that's
done from home and we are partnering
with school districts and we are
partnering with preschools particularly
head start grantees across the country
to support teachers and to deliver khan
academy kids
to as many students as possible so if
you
are a school district administrator or
you know of one you can email khan kids
partners at khanacademy.org
and that's where you can reach one of us
who will help support your district or
preschool to get khan academy kids out
there for parents and teachers and most
importantly for students
excellent
all right i'm going to take another
fun question from youtube
cokie wants to know
why is peck a baby bird
oh
um
well
i think i don't i i this is actually
putting me on the spot i don't know how
old peck is maybe one of our um super
users knows more about peck than i do
quick is certainly the smallest of our
characters in size um but you know
certainly
very a very very interesting diverse
character don't let size fool you when
it comes to peck uh but i'll have to
check with our our creative team our
animators our illustrators here who
created peck um to to really check in on
and why he he at least seems younger i'm
not sure that he is uh but i'll check
excellent excellent it's always good to
uh stump the the hosts and the guests
sometimes so good question
all right we are just about out of time
let me just close by asking what are you
most excited about in the year ahead
oh
i think it's got to be seeing kids back
in school i mean i think i took it for
granted you know going out and visiting
schools and
uh you know all the noise and the mess
and the joy that goes with a classroom
that's in full swing and i am just so
excited kristen to to see that again to
to see kids uh spending time together
and and to you know
get off zoom so you know we we might
have to wait a little longer and i'm
glad everyone's being really patient but
i i'd have to say that that is my my
dream for this coming school year
excellent thank you so much for joining
us thanks to all of you who have been
listening account academy kids you can
find it in whatever app store you use
and prefer for your devices thank you
and we'll see you all next time
thanks kristin
you